It has been one hundred
and twenty-one days
since the aliens
invaded our world.
♪♪
We have suffered.
We have sacrificed
lives,
loved ones.
Connection, it's the
only chance we'll have
to learn what they want.
And how to stop them.
My fellow global citizens,
look up.
This is our enemy.
Together we will win this war.
The aliens,
somehow connected us.
This is our last
chance for survival.
Anyway, it sounds mental.
Yeah, it does sound mental,
but the whole world's
mental, right?
♪♪
The world out there
is falling apart.
I would do anything to hold
this family together.
They adapted. We'll adapt.
What if we could save everybody?
Come back!
If you wanna win the war,
you fight back.
Ahhh!
♪♪
The answers
are here.
Are you sure you
want to do this?
♪♪